okay next game where this behemoth
from the netherlands
this is the netherlands yes
ah the grunfeld well i haven't played d4
for so long time
so i don't have any
detailed idea what to do
because i go for the main setup
maybe this one
i don't really know the the book moves
check
hmm i vaguely remember some kasparov
game
in this kind of position
yeah i haven't played the grunfeld for
ages
as white
yeah this looks like a decent position
h3 can even take i guess
f4 then he might play night g4
no idea
maybe he's six now
hmm yeah it's
it's looking like pretty standard green
for that stuff
black seems to be okay
maybe take and then f5 just play
as directly as possible
it looks like white should get something
going really quickly
otherwise black will be
very much okay with the two bishops okay
was afraid of f5 i guess
and now e5 to
block in here this bishop
the whole time we can take on a2 i guess
we both didn't really calculate anything
there and
just trusted each other that this move
isn't good
not sure you could also go
rook d2 now
it doesn't
maybe knight queen to c4 to cover all
this and
keep an eye on e6 i like this move
yeah and he also didn't have
didn't didn't have so many squares for
the queen
let's try to get the knight on better
squares now
this could be good for white
okay what now
maybe a4 now the queen
doesn't have any square
how to make progress in this position
interesting
do i need to re-route the knight but
it's really a good position here
i cannot do much maybe just
go for knight g5 at some point
doubling on the f5 and then knight g5
okay now with tempo
this must be good
queen f4 this isn't
this isn't a mate but maybe just
just the other rook i don't think he can
afford to take on e5
would be surprising now i have to check
in queen h4
should be okay
check time warning
queen edge for now
check
my thread is rook g7 and mate
on f8 plus h7
can i just take in queen e7 it doesn't
even have a check
so it should be working
black resigns yeah
well i certainly didn't play play the
opening well but
somehow
this position unless he's
he he can do something really quickly
now
maybe he needs to take on a2 to get the
queen into the game
after this move i think his queen is out
of play and i can just
improve the position yeah i think he
needs to take on a2
at some point maybe
yeah just just here i play rook a1
of course i can play rook a1 then queen
d2
rook a7 and then i don't know queen d3
or something
black should be okay here it's got very
active pieces
yeah he needs to do this